-The President's ex-campaign
chairman has flipped on him
and his Supreme Court nominee
has been imperiled
by a serious
sexual-assault allegation.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-One by one,
Trump's closest aides
have turned on him and struck
plea deals with prosecutors.
But there was one, who,
for months, refused to cave,
and that was his ex-campaign
chairman, Paul Manafort.
Manafort went all the way
to trial.
And to ensure
Manafort's loyalty,
Trump repeatedly praised him.
-I think the whole
Manafort trial is very sad
when you look
at what's going on there.
I think it's a very sad day
for our country.
He worked for me for
a very short period of time.
But you know what?
He happens to be
a very good person.
Paul Manafort's a good man.
He was with Ronald Reagan.
He was with a lot of different
people over the years,
and I feel very sad about that.
It doesn't involve me,
but I still feel --
You know, it's a very sad thing
that happened.
This has nothing to do
with Russian collusion.
-I like how Trump
tries to praise Manafort,
but his instinct for
self-preservation
keeps leaking through.
[ Laughter ]
"Paul is a very good friend,
whom I barely know,
and his crimes
had nothing to do with me,
his very good friend."
[ Laughter ]
Also, do you only
give interviews on tarmacs now?
[ Laughter ]
Trump's strategy
for dealing with reporters
is to always be near something
louder than him.
"Mr. President, why is everyone
around you a criminal?"
"I'm sorry!
You'll have to speak up!
I'm making wood chips!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Gonna catch on soon
with Sarah Sanders.
She's gonna
give press conferences
while making daiquiris.
[ Laughter ]
"That is not something I've
spoken to the President about."
[ Imitates blender
motor whirring ]
[ Laughter ]
So there you go --
Trump heaped praise on Manafort,
calling him a brave
and wonderful man
who would,
under no circumstances, flip.
-Paul Manafort has flipped.
-During an hour-long hearing
in federal court,
Manafort pleaded guilty
to two felony counts
related to his foreign lobbying.
Even more significantly,
he agreed to cooperate
in Special Counsel
Robert Mueller's
Russia investigation by
providing unspecified documents
and testifying
before the grand jury.
-Wow!
Your friend just flipped on you.
What do you say to that?
[ Engine whirring loudly ]
I said your friend
just flipped on you!
What do you --
Never mind.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pointless.
And Manafort didn't just
have to plead guilty
and agree to cooperate.
He also had to give up
his lavish lifestyle,
including an apartment
in Donald Trump's
most famous building.
-As part of his punishment,
Manafort agreed to forfeit
bank accounts, life insurance,
and several properties,
including his apartment
in Trump Tower.
-You know what
the best burn would be?
The best burn would be
if Robert Mueller
took the apartment.
[ Laughter ]
If Mueller moved in, he would be
the kind of tenant Trump hates.
"Hey, the guy in 4C went through
the recycling again.
He says your mixing your paper
and your plastic."
"I hate that guy so much."
[ Laughter ]
For the prosecution,
there was maybe no one
more valuable than Manafort.
He knows as much about what
happened in 2016 as anyone.
For example,
he was actually in
that infamous
Trump Tower meeting
with the Russians in 2016.
And he seems to know
a lot about Trump's finances
and connections to Russians.
As you can tell from this clip,
from the 2016 campaign,
which is truly
one of our favorites.
-So to be clear, Mr. Trump
has no financial relationships
with any Russian oligarchs?
-That's what he said.
I -- I -- That's what I said.
That's obviously what the --
our position is.
-How was that guy a successful
criminal for so long?!
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean, that was one.
He got one question
about Trump's finances,
and he broke down
like a malfunctioning
Chuck E. Cheese robot.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Uh, that --
that's what he said.
That's -- That --
That's what he --
That's what I --
Happy birthday to yo--
Ha-Ha-Ha-Happy birth--
Buh-uuh-buuh!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Mom, the mouse is smoking!"
[ Laughter ]
So, for months now, the screws
have been tightening on Trump,
but he seemed to have
one last ace in the hole --
his Supreme Court nominee,
Brett Kavanaugh.
If Kavanaugh makes it
onto the court,
he could very well rule
on key aspects of Trump's case.
And Kavanaugh has been a loyal,
partisan Republican
whose views on executive power
could not be friendlier
to Trump.
Throughout
his confirmation hearings,
Kavanaugh has refused to take
positions on legal issues
that could be crucial
to Trump's survival.
-Trump claims he has an absolute
right to pardon himself.
Does he?
-The question of self-pardons is
something I've never analyzed.
-Can a sitting President
be required to respond
to a subpoena?
-So that's
a hypothetical question.
-Should a president
use his or her authority
to pressure executive
or independent agency officials
into carrying out directives
for purely political purposes?
-I need to stay
not just away from the line
but three ZIP codes away
from the line
of current events or politics.
-Hey, you don't get to stay
three ZIP codes away
from Donald Trump.
Some of us
are entire states away
and we can still hear him
screaming over the sound
of a jet engine.
[ Laughter ]
Also, nothing says
you're not from New York
more than thinking three ZIP
codes away is a large distance.
[ Laughter ]
In New York, three ZIP codes
is like two Starbucks away.
[ Laughter ]
Now, when this process started,
it seemed to many like Kavanaugh
would sail through,
given that Republicans
control the Senate.
But then, last week,
Senate Democrats disclosed
that they had referred
a complaint regarding Kavanaugh
to the FBI
for investigation.
Kavanaugh denied it,
and Republicans responded
by rushing to defend him.
-65 women stepping forward
to defend
President Trump's Supreme Court
nominee Brett Kavanaugh.
-Right after we saw
these allegations came out,
we heard from 65 women
defending him in a letter
to Senate Judiciary Committee
Chair Chuck Grassley
and Senator Feinstein.
So this was immediate response.
-You know what's
a little incriminating?
If you're accused
of sexual assault
and you just happen
to have on hand
a list of other women
you didn't sexually assault.
[ Laughter ]
If the cops come to your house
and say they want to ask you
about a murder,
and you come to the door
with a list of people
you didn't murder...
[ Laughter ]
...you'll still be a suspect
in that murder.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Every one of these people
is alive."
Alive, alive, alive, alive.
And yet despite the seriousness
of these allegations,
Republicans
and right-wing pundits
immediately went
on the offensive.
Fox News host Jeanine Pirro,
for example,
attacked California Senator
Dianne Feinstein
for keeping
the complaint confidential,
at the woman's request,
and implied that she might not
even be a real person.
-When you get the letter,
what do you do
to make sure it's real?
That the person is even real?
Given the left's penchant
to buy fake dossiers,
make up facts,
and collude with the media
to sabotage even the president
of the United States,
forgive me if I think
it's all hogwash.
Why would you wait
to even send it to the FBI?
Is it because nothing in you
and your pack of demon rats --
that's what I said,
demon rats --
a.k.a. Democrats bag of tricks,
was working against Kavanaugh?
-Jeanine,
you don't have to clarify
that you said "demon rats."
[ Laughter ]
You look and sound like a person
who uses "demon rats"
all the time.
[ Laughter ]
If your delivery guy
was five minutes late,
I'm pretty sure
you'd call him a demon rat.
[ Laughter ]
"When I order my egg rolls..."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"...I want them
when they're hot!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Also, you're calling Democrats
demon rats?
Have you seen the guys
who work in this White House?
I'm pretty sure Stephen Miller
is a demon who eats rats.
[ Laughter and applause ]
If you check
the White House fridge,
his lunch looks like this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And then there was Louisiana
Senator John Kennedy,
who was asked
about the allegations
and chose to complain about
the way Democrats have behaved
throughout Kavanaugh's
confirmation hearings.
-What do you make of this
allegation against Kavanaugh
back when he was a teenager?
Do you think it'll do anything
to derail his nomination,
his confirmation?
-I'm fairly confident
that our Founding Fathers
did not intend the process
to work this way.
So far, it's pretty much been
an intergalactic freak show.
-Excuse me. Have you seen
the guy you voted for?
Talk about
an intergalactic freak show.
Trump looks like an extra
from the waiting-room scene
in "Beetlejuice."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then, yesterday -- yesterday,
the author of the letter,
Christine Blasey Ford,
came forward
and spoke on the record
to "The Washington Post."
She provided therapist notes
from 2012
to corroborate her story,
making clear
that the allegations
are, indeed, credible.
And again,
the right tried to discredit her
or ignore the allegations
altogether.
Republicans on
the Senate Judiciary Committee
released a statement, calling
them "uncorroborated allegations
from more than 35 years ago,
during high school."
And when a reporter tracked down
Maine Senator Susan Collins
in the D.C. airport,
she wouldn't say
if Kavanaugh's hearing
should be delayed.
In fact,
she wouldn't even stop walking.
-Well, I obviously
was very surprised.
And, uh, it's -- it's an issue
that I brought up with him
last Friday, and he denied,
as he did
in his written statement.
That's really all I have
to say at this point.
-What do you think?
should the committee vote
coming up here this week?
-I'm going to be talking
with my colleagues,
but I really don't have anything
to add at this point.
-Do you believe the accuser?
-I don't know enough to make
a judgment at this point.
-She really covered some ground
in that interview.
[ Laughter ]
If that was New York,
she would have walked through
three [bleep] ZIP codes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, Republicans
are really getting desperate
to avoid reporters.
Mitch McConnell actually flies
inside his checked luggage now.
[ Laughter ]
And, generally speaking,
when you're running away
from a reporter asking you about
sexual-assault allegations,
you're on the wrong side
of history.
And this isn't even
the first entry in this genre.
Last year, Alabama Congressman
Mo Brooks literally
ran down a flight of stairs
as a reporter chased after him,
asking about the allegations
against Alabama Senate candidate
Roy Moore.
-"Aww, why'd I wear
my tap shoes?!"
[ Laughter ]
"Of all the days
to wear my tap shoes."
[ Applause ]
Seriously, at this point,
news networks are gonna
just have to start
hiring faster journalists.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And then, there were
the Republicans who made clear
that they were eager to believe
Kavanaugh and dismissed Ford.
Today, for example, after one
phone call with Kavanaugh,
Utah Senator Orrin Hatch
said he believed Ford
had gotten her story wrong.
-I talked to him
on the phone today.
-And what did he say to you?
-Well, he didn't do that.
That he wasn't at the party.
So, you know, there's clearly --
somebody's mixed up.
-She was mixed up?
You literally
once tried to take
an invisible pair of glasses off
your face during a hearing.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, late today, it was reported
that Kavanaugh and Ford will
testify in public next week.
Republicans should
honor her courage,
take her allegations seriously,
and stop dismissing her,
because right now,
if you ask them
if they still stand
behind Kavanaugh, they say...
-I -- That's what I said --
That's obviously what the --
our position is.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]